jean berthier 90 ans est l'un des
premiers habitants des yvelines à s'être
fait vacciner
en tout ce sont 15 volontaires sur 39
résidents de l'ehpad mon repos située à
sartrouville qui ont pu en bénéficier
il n'y a qu'une solution où je fais pas
vacciner en résultera pas malade et où
ça vacciner on espère être protégé et en
tous les cas cette phrase moyens on a
des feuilles et de faire baisser décor
et pour montrer l'exemple le directeur
du groupe des ehpad s'est lui aussi fait
vacciner comme dirigeant du groupe g
considéré que c'était important de
montrer l'exemple à la fois pour montrer
à nos résidents et à leurs proches que
on avait confiance dans ceux dans ce
vaccin et puis ensuite pour susciter un
effet d'entraînement auprès de tous les
salariés du groupe
tous les soignants qui s'occupe des
résidents pour que lorsque le moment
sera venu pour eux ils soient
volontaires ou eux aussi pour se faire
vacciner 80 à 90 % des résidents se
feront vacciner par la suite mais il n'y
a aucune obligation
il ya eu un premier courrier qui a été
envoyé aux familles donc c'était une
déclaration d'intention de vaccination
on a eu des retours des familles
certaines familles ont lissé les
résidents prendre la décision par eux
mêmes et non il n'y a aucune obligation
au coeur résidents ne sera mis à part
s'il se fait pas vacciner c'est le libre
choix de chacun
un acheminement compliqué puisque les
vaccins sont conservées cinq parfums qu
à une température de moins 80 degrés ils
sont stockés dans un réfrigérateur dans
le pôle de soins de l'établissement
et puis au fur et à mesure on sort les
petites ampoules on les ramène à
température ambiante ça prend quelques
minutes et on prépare 5 seringue avec un
flacon de vaccins après avoir
reconstitué ce vaccin c'est une semaine
pilote de vaccination en france qui
touche bientôt à sa fin
une deuxième dose sera administré dans
21 jours après la première injection
pour augmenter le taux d'immunisation